Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Steve Schmidt, who's a renowned American
political strategist, formerly of the 2008
McCain campaign and many other campaigns,
founder of The Warning, a newsletter, podcast
and YouTube channel as well.
Steve, great to have you on.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 4: Good to be with you.
My pleasure.
Speaker 1: So where are you on the Republican
Party at this point in time?
I'm curious because your views have certainly
evolved over time.
I mean, our audience may, may or may not know
about them.
Speaker 4: Well, I founded the Lincoln Project
in 2020 to oppose Donald Trump.
I was Arnold Schwarzenegger's campaign manager.
I was a top strategist for George W Bush.
I served in the Bush White House.
But I have always recognized that Donald Trump
was a profound threat to the republic along
with every other person in the Republican
Party.
The differences are a few of us, when we said
never meant it.
And overwhelmingly, as in 99.99% of every
person involved in the institutional Republican
Party allowed themselves to perpetuate a piece
what I regard as the most dangerous threat
that the country has faced internally since
the Civil War.
And what I view the Republican Party as as
a in a two party system in this country is
a profound threat that has been hijacked by
a faction that has turned against fundamental
American concepts such as democracy and pluralism.
And all of it is is deeply ground in walking
away from the results of an election.
And I just last thing I'll say about that.
I'm the person who placed the phone call for
John McCain to Barack Obama.
And, you know, I was the first Republican
in America to say the words, congratulations,
Mr. President elect, before I handed the phone
to him.
And so this is elemental, you know, in a free
society.
And that's what the parties walked away from.
Speaker 1: So as far as policy goes, I mean,
are you still like a low tax guy?
You want to reduce abortion or have your views
also changed over time?
Speaker 4: I was a moderate Republican from
New Jersey.
Right.
So the north Eastern tradition of Republicanism
was not ideological.
It wasn't Southern, it wasn't evangelical.
The Republican Party in the Northeastern states
was a Reform party, and it typically took
power after the excesses of the machine run
party controlled Democrats of those states.
So you always had nine ideological Republicans
Jacob Javits, Christie Whitman, Tom Kaine
in New Jersey that ran on records of of environmentalism.
I've always supported a woman's right to choose.
And I was one of the very earliest people
with any profile in the country to come out
in favor of gay marriage in the Republican
Party.
I worked for the ACLU leading the marriage
equality campaign.
So I don't think that you can look seriously
into a camera as a Republican and say, hey,
this is a fiscally conservative party.
There is no fiscally conservative party in
America.
You have two wildly spending political parties
that have accumulated $32 trillion in national
debt.
If you look at baby boomer presidencies, Bill
Clinton was the most fiscally responsible.
Barack Obama was number two.
George Bush was number three, and Donald Trump
was the wildest spender of them all.
Speaker 1: When you mention New Jersey, you
know, when I look at the Republican primary
field now is a guy from the progressive left.
It seems so obvious to me that Chris Christie
is by far the most competent and qualified
person running in that primary.
And if you said to me, David, the next president
will be someone currently running in the Republican
primary, it would be so obvious to me that
Chris Christie would be my choice.
He's polling 1%.
Okay.
We don't yet have polling from after his announcement.
What is your sense of whether there is any
desire among the current Republican Party
for someone like a Chris Christie?
Speaker 4: Well, I look, I think it is a mistake
for people to look at Chris Christie and just
to blithely say he has no chance.
Reality is.
In order to win the Republican nomination,
you have to win somewhere first.
So when you look at this right now, could
Tim Scott win in Iowa?
Tim Scott can win in Iowa.
I think he's the only person who can beat
Trump in Iowa.
Who's in the field right now?
And Chris Christie win in New Hampshire.
Is it possible if you look at Chris Christie's
town hall from the other night and you look,
for example, at Tim Ryan's town hall that
he did on Fox News and he basically said many
of the same things that Chris Christie did,
you watch that FOX audience in people's faces
are contorted and twisted in anger as he's
telling them, Right, that Trump lost the election.
You had the guy with the MAGA hat.
No, we saw the Trump Town Hall on CNN when
people are cheering because Trump had just
been found guilty of sexual abuse.
Right.
You didn't see any of that in that audience
in New Hampshire.
Right.
Of people who turned out to Chris Christie.
You if you watch that closely on a body language
perspective, those people are not rejecting
what he's saying.
So now, however, it is that that Chris got
there right over seven long years.
And I'm going to I'm going to step.
I'm going to I'm just going to skip that whole
part of it because I think it's tedious.
We all we all know his record is Stepford
Wife appearance, but he's the only person
in the race, such as it is, who's just telling
the truth right now.
Now, he hasn't always been truthful now on
these issues to say to say the least.
But right in the race right now, he's our
guy.
He's your guy.
He's my guy because he's the only guy who's
saying things that heretofore no one has said
to these audiences.
Any person who's who's running have lived
in a delusion sphere.
And good for Chris Christie.
Better late than never is is saying for a
reason, you know, that he's bringing up the
manifest corruption and all the other all
the other issues.
Is he flawed?
Of course he is flawed.
But, you know, it's he's the best that they
got right now.
And there is a truth teller in the race, and
that hasn't been the case.
The only group that that has ever confronted
him effectively is the group that I started.
It indisputably drew blood in the in the sixth
year of Trump's presence on the national stage.
So in turn, I hope Christie can do that in.
Speaker 1: Terms of the other non-Trump people
that are running.
We've seen pretty significant hesitation to
really go after Trump.
Christie and his town hall was direct, and
he said the path to the nomination is through
Trump and Trump's going to try to go through
me.
I'm going to try to go through him with everybody
else.
You know, Nikki Haley early on would basically
just chalk it up to I'm a woman and I'm younger
and I'm a person of color.
And Tim Scott, when he was given the opportunity
to really draw distinctions with Trump, sort
of said the contrast is going to be clear.
And what exactly he meant by that.
I don't know what he meant.
DeSantis is starting to criticize Trump a
little, but it seems that there's this idea
that if they are there and then Trump gets
arrested three more times and maybe it pulls
him off the campaign trail, they will be able
to swoop in and somehow pick up Trump supporters
by virtue of not having really attacked Trump
at this early stage.
Is that viable?
And number two, if it is, it can't be viable
for all of them.
It seems maybe for one of them that would
work.
Speaker 4: It's it's not viable for any of
them.
Look, at the end of the day, it's a position
that's rooted in a fundamental delusional
dishonesty.
And if you look at what a presidential contest
is, the race for the presidency in the United
States is the greatest non-lethal competition
in the world.
There's nothing there is nothing like it.
There is no game.
There is no sport.
There is nothing that is as intense as focused
as this.
And so what this is, as David Axelrod once
said, is an MRI for the soul.
Right.
This is a character test.
And so each of these people put aside their
beliefs, their ideology, their political label.
They're weak and they're afraid.
They're terrified of being tweeted about by
Donald Trump.
Mike Pence is race has no rationale whatsoever.
His former boss, the president, tried to have
him hang in and he just now will only say,
well, he endangered me and all the.
And my family.
Yeah.
The American people in our full range of our
vast menagerie.
Right of beliefs and everything else from
left to right.
The American people will not vote for weaklings,
will not vote for spinelessness.
Right.
So so every one of these people in exclusively
right there, all the people that played a
previous role as Trump sycophants who won't
tell the truth about him now, what they what
they prove is their softness and is disqualifying.
So all of these people, whether it's the North
Dakota governor who could, let's say, right.
And I've never seen the guy.
I couldn't pick him out of a lineup.
I don't know if he's good or not.
He can talk or not.
But but could there be a reform minded governor
from a small state in the tradition of a Jimmy
Carter in 1976?
Is there space for that in the Republican
Party?
There is.
But you asked the North Dakota governor, right.
Well, what about his claims about the stolen
election?
Right.
What about him saying this?
Are you going to say a word?
It's like he's in the witness protection program,
Right?
You know, he's like facing down Pablo Escobar
at trial.
He won't.
Nada.
Right.
And it's disqualifying.
Speaker 1: When it comes to the economy.
There's been this idea for a long time in
American politics that when you look at a
reelection of a sitting president, so much
of it is guided by the state of the economy.
However, there's this strange thing happening
right now where on Monday I looked at every
indicator that's usually used.
How is the stock market been doing?
What's the unemployment rate?
Job creation numbers, GDP, inflation, trade,
balance.
Right.
We look at all of it.
It all looks pretty okay.
Unremarkable or like pretty good.
And yet all the time on my YouTube channel,
I see comments from people saying you're you're
worried because the economy is a disaster.
Biden has failed on the economy.
And when I say, well, show me a metric that
proves that people will write to me, they'll
say, well, if you compare wages to housing
costs, you know, we're looking pretty deep
here to find something that would point to
an economy that's not at minimum, okay, if
not cruising along pretty, pretty well.
What's your view on this issue?
Maybe not so much about the state of the economy,
but the disconnect about even if the metrics
look fine, the story is still that the economy
is terrible.
Speaker 4: What I would say what I would say
about that is what you're talking about is
the difference between emotion and rationality.
Right.
And so so the question you're asking is a
question about a feeling, right?
Not a not a question about the weather.
Right.
So you go outside, it's 85 degrees and sunny
and someone says, this is a terrible day.
You look at me and you say, it's obviously
not.
It's a beautiful.
Right.
But but but this is much more subjective.
Right?
So first off, and you look at some of the
ratings decline on cable, for example, cable
news, it makes perfect sense.
I mean, 80% of the people that appear on CNN,
for example, on any given day or appearing
from Washington, DC and almost none of those
people make under a couple of million dollars
a year.
So so they are in a place that is detached
from reality.
They live in a rarefied air and there is a
lack of appreciation across the board for
the fact of 40% of the country doesn't have
$400 cash available.
That enormous percentages of the E one, two,
three, four ranks in the military deal with
food insecurity issues.
Go look at the payday lending outside of a
military base.
Does any normal person have access to a return
on the stock market in the sense of here's
a stock, this company has a value, it's going
to grow.
This is all computer trading against algorithms
at the edge of a moment of profound disruption
caused by technology, globalization.
And there's a lack of an animating vision
that communicates to people what's what's
going to happen next.
So I think that all of Biden's deficiencies
in, in a political sense, are rooted in a
in an awful failure of communications.
And that is in that is where that is very,
very worrying.
Right.
If you're if you're a football team, you have
to throw the ball.
You're the president of the United States
running for reelection in a fraud time against
a massive, massive, massive, massive misinformation
propaganda net.
Work, all of it put together.
You have to communicate like Tom Brady throws
that football.
And even the most generous, generous fan of
the of the president has to understand has
to appreciate that that there is a massive
communication deficit.
In the end, the evidence of that is that this
radical extremist anti-American movement has
not been crushed politically.
It's still alive and it's still in a position
to take power.
And this next election has to be the place
where it's put away for good.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with political
strategist Steve Schmidt.
He is the founder of The Warning.
And we will link to the newsletter, podcast
and YouTube channel.
Steve, really appreciate your time and insights
today.
Speaker 4: My pleasure to be with you.